accept yourself just the way you are
what does that say about who I should
become is that just now off the table
because I'm already good enough in every
way so am I done or something get the
hell up get your act together adopt some
responsibility put your life together
develop a vision unfold all those
manifold possibilities that lurk within
be a force for good in the world and
that'll be the adventure of your life
a free market solution to the problem of
marginalization is something like that
the offering of a true diversity it's
like yeah you're only five foot two so
you can't play basketball you know but
you might be a damn good jockey exactly
we have enough games exactly exactly
that and then people can trade on their
idiosyncrasies and you see this is an
argument that free market types haven't
made to the diversity types it's like
well the reason you want a free market
is to provide a diverse number of games
so the marginalized can find a center
even if you think about institutional
purpose right you were talking about the
level of individuals in the marginalized
side and so I agree with that that's one
form of diverse approaches to diversity
here's a different approach a diverse
approaches to diversity is diversity of
institutional purpose but the problem
with these you know ESG or Dei
three-letter acronyms is what are they
effectively saying they're saying that
no no you can't have your own
distinctive purpose everyone's purpose
must be common to advance environmental
social and governance goals diversity
equity and inclusion goals that's a
denial of diversity if you run an
institution you have one question why do
we exist
period have a good answer to that
question and then say what type of
diversity you espouse that's really just
in service of advancing that
institutional purpose different types of
Institutions should want different kinds
of diversity and and they should be
transparent about what types of
diversity they don't want
foreign
[Music]
I'm very happy today to talk with vivec
Rama Swami who has just announced his
candidacy for the American presidency
and is going to well hopefully change
the political landscape in doing so the
vague is an American Business leader and
New York Times best-selling author of
woke Inc inside corporate America's
social justice scam along with his
second book nation of victims
identity Politics the death of Merit and
the path back to Excellence
born and raised in Cincinnati Ohio he
often recounts the sage advice from his
father
stand out then you might as well be
outstanding this set the course for his
life a nationally ranked tennis player
valedictorian of his high school Saint
Xavier he went on to graduate summa
laude in biology from Harvard and then
received his JD from Yale law school
while working at a hedge fund he then
started a biotech company Roy vant
Sciences
where he oversold
that it became FDA approved
in 2022 is an important side note he
founded strive an ohio-based asset
management firm that directly competes
with asset managers like BlackRock State
Street and Vanguard
who use the money of everyday citizens
that includes you by the way to advance
environmental and social agendas that
many citizens and capital owners
disagree with that's a far more
important issue than you might think and
we're going to discuss that a lot as we
proceed through our conversation today
well hello Vivek and everyone watching
it's uh
on here on the YouTube platform it's
always good to have everybody's time and
attention Vivek ramaswamy who I'm
talking to today is running for
president which seems to be quite the
Preposterous thing to do for anyone I
would say uh this new this next 2024
election is going to be some interesting
uh contest as far as I can tell we're
not going to have seen anything like it
enough the fact that you threw your hat
in the ring I think is part and parcel
of the whole show uh so so let's start
let's start by just
exploring why it is that you decided to
do this and we should do that why did
you decide to do this and what is it
that you hope to accomplish by making
this run so let's start with why you're
doing it
so you know some of the journey I've
been on over the last few years but I
think that's what led me to the doorstep
I've been addressing for the last few
years this merger of state power and
corporate power that together do what
neither can do on its own and and part
of me is long believed that the
Republican Party in the United States is
behind by 40 years right reciting
slogans they memorized in 1980 when the
real threat to Liberty today is
different so I've taken on the woke
industrial complex in America through
the books I've written through traveling
the country most recently taking on the
ESG Movement by starting strive last
year and that's where my headspace was I
did not think I was going into politics
I thought that I wanted to actually
avoid the limiting shackles of partisan
politics it just felt so constraining I
thought of running for the U.S Senate I
decided not to do that I said no no I
want to do this independently as an
independent voice thought leader author
and then you know look I had successful
I successfully built a biotech company
before they put those skills to work
starting strive that was where my
exclusive Focus was going to be and I'm
proud to say I think we are already
having major impact on the market
through my work at strive and even just
through putting a spotlight on the
problem
but I got to be really honest about this
and this was the realization that dawned
on me after you know years into that
Journey
is that it does take
Tango okay and what I mean by that is
the top-down version of this problem the
cynical exploitation of corporate power
and state power to Shackle the human
spirit I think is only half the issue
because that only works if there's a
culture that's really willing to buy it
up it only works if there's a populist
that's buying up what they're selling
and to me I think that requires every
one of us to look deeply in the mirror
and ask ourselves what is it about us as
a people that wants us to bend the knee
or that makes us want to bend the knee
to the powers that be that wants us to
embrace these new secular religions and
that wasn't quite a problem that I was
going to be able to address even through
Market action in taking on BlackRock or
the ESG forces in capital markets and
that's really what when don don made it
there was no better way to drive a
cultural Revival in America than to
successfully and successfully is an
important part of this but then to
successfully run for president and the
whole premise of my campaign pain is
actually to define a national identity
answer the question of what it means to
be an American in the year 2023 I do not
believe we have a good answer to that
question in this country I'm on a
mission to deliver an answer to that
question and my basic premise here is
that our absence of that answer that is
the black hole at the center of our
nation's soul that is what allows wokism
and gender ideology and climatism and
covetism to fill the void these are
secular religions that prey on that
vacuum if we can fill that vacuum with
say a vision of national identity that
runs so deep that it dilutes these other
agendas to irrelevance that is how we
win and I believe that there isn't a
candidate in this field I believe who's
quite up to that challenge I'm not sure
I am either but I do believe that I'm
going to give it the best shot that we
have which is why I'm running
okay well you you brought up a lot of
very complex issues in that just
description of your motives and so I'm
going to walk through them one by one to
unpack them for everybody because you
know you said the Republicans are 40
years behind it I think that's probably
true of of uh organizations like the UN
as well and and 40 years is a long time
given how much has changed in the last
10 years and what that means is that
the average person who's watching and
listening to this is also behind and
isn't even aware of of what uh acronyms
like ESG mean or why they should really
give a damn I just interviewed the uh
CEO of the national uh uh uh what's the
organization State Treasures
organization ah I said it's cheap it's a
financial officers organization now
there's 28 States I know I know them
yeah yeah yeah well they're pushing hard
back against the the ASG movement and
and but you know we talked about in that
podcast the fact that people don't even
know what the hell that means now you
opened your description essentially I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but from my perspective you opened your
your description of your motives with a
statement about what essentially boils
down to a kind of fascist collusion and
what we're seeing is an amalgam of power
that's corporate which of course the
left Wingers complain about that's
government which the right Wingers
complain about and then of media which
everybody complains about and rightly so
and there's this idea that seems to be
raining in the upper echelons of the
power structures that
that we're facing an apocalyptic
emergency of such magnitude whatever the
emergency happens to be that they should
be conveniently seated all the power and
one of the fronts upon which that battle
is being fought is the ESG movement and
so do you want to walk through that for
everyone just to bring them up to date
absolutely I mean this has been
something of my obsession over the last
several years and not just as a
commentator but as a doer and as an
entrepreneur too so the the issue with
the ESG movement it stands for
environmental social and governance
factors it's designed to sound boring
for a reason my general rule of thumb is
if it sounds like a three-letter acronym
that bores you that's a good sign that
you should be paying more attention
because it was designed to bore you what
what this whole game is about is using
private power using Capital markets to
accomplish through the back door what
government could not get done through
the front door under the Constitution so
I'll tell you what it is and then I'll
walk through the history of how we got
there because that's also pretty
important too what the essence of the
ESG movement is what it does is it uses
the money of everyday citizens Americans
but Canadians too Australians and
Western Europeans it uses the money of
everyday citizens
to invest in companies and to vote their
shares in ways that Advance one-sided
Progressive agendas environmental and
social agendas that most of those people
do not agree with that most of those
people did not know were actually being
Advanced with their own money and which
don't Advance the financial best
interests of most people whose money is
actually used so what does that mean
think about yourself saving in a
retirement account or a 401k account or
a brokerage account you think that the
person who's managing that money is
exclusively looking after your best
financial interests
turns out they're not they're also
looking after advancing these other
environmental and social goals who are
these institutions they're Asset
Management firms like BlackRock or State
Street or Vanguard or Invesco or
countless others
that have signed a pledge to say that
they're going to align all of their
underlying companies with the goals of
the Paris climate Accords with Net Zero
standards by 2050 with modern diversity
equity and inclusion standards and those
three or four firms alone manage about
20 trillion dollars maybe even a little
bit more that's more than the US GDP
right now in the hands of three to four
financial institutions but they're not
using their money to do it they're using
most money they're using the money of
probably most listeners to this exchange
right now people watching this good
chances that their money their
retirement accounts their brokerage
accounts are being used to tell
companies like apple to adopt racial
Equity audits that Apple's board
initially did not want to adopt to tell
companies like Chevron to adopt scope 3
emissions caps which I can talk about
what that means but that Chevron did not
want to adopt and that most people
watching this probably didn't want to
force on Chevron either but their money
was used to do it anyway that's what
this ESG movement is all about so how
did we get here is actually a really
important question
and a lot of this began there were two
big Milestones seeing the supercharging
of this ESG movement in our economy and
in capital markets the first one which I
think of as the big bang that really set
the whole thing for all intents and
purposes into motion was the 2008
financial crisis what happened in the 08
financial crisis and by the way I had a
front row seat to this I got my first
job in New York at an elite hedge fund
in the fall of 2007 you know the fund I
worked at got an honorable mention in
Michael Lewis's book The Big Short this
is my first job out of college this is
this is fun stuff for me right I didn't
a lot of people lost a lot of money in
on Wall Street I didn't have any money
so it didn't matter to me it was more of
a learning experience which was a pretty
rich one but I had a front row seat what
happened was
in the aftermath of the 08 crisis
Republicans it's worth remembering this
Republicans in this country bailed out
the big Banks which I don't know what
your view is Dr Peterson I view that as
a major mistake it's a cardinal sin the
Bush Administration and Hank Paulson a
CEO and alumnus of Goldman Sachs used
public taxpayer funds to bail out
Goldman Sachs while letting his
competitors fail this was crony
capitalism all the way down
and the left actually had a point in
this country Occupy Wall Street was born
and what they said is look if you're
going to play that crony capitalist game
then you know what we're going to play
our game we're just going to take money
from your wealthy corporate fat cat
pockets and redistribute it to poor
people to help poor people because
that's what we on the far left want to
do on the Occupy Wall Street movement
but right around that time there was
there was a fissure in the left-wing
movement in this country where there was
the birth of this new let's call it the
woke left Barack Obama had just been
elected the first black president United
States there was a lot of cultural
currents in the U.S that said well wait
a minute there the real problem isn't
quite economic Injustice or poverty it's
really racial Injustice and misogyny and
bigotry and by the way climate change
this is supposed to Al Gore's
Inconvenient Truth this actually
presented the opportunity of a
generation for Wall Street to say that
no no okay guys we'll make a deal with
you we will use our corporate power use
our money really your money
to applaud diversity and inclusion to
put token minorities on corporate boards
to Muse about this racially disparate
impact of climate change from the
mountaintops of Davos after flying there
in a private jet we'll do all of these
things
but we don't do it for free
we expect the new Left to look the other
way when it comes to leaving our
corporate power intact and so they
defend Occupy Wall Street most people
don't even remember what Occupy Wall
Street is it went by the wayside and
that's how the birth of this new what
I've sometimes called woke industrial or
ESG industrial complex was born where
Wall Street said that you know what if
you can't beat us join us and that's
exactly what happened so that was the
first thing do you think it was that do
you think it was that conscious
or do you think that it was that was the
consequence of a thousand micro
decisions you know I mean were there
but it's easy to see us okay it was the
latter yeah I mean this is not this is
not a smoke-filled room where there was
some sort of meeting in the back of
Goldman Sachs has brought boardroom on
85 Broad Street in lower Manhattan no
this isn't and that's
an ethical conspiracy theory this isn't
an emergent reality right
and when they think about what a
conspiracy theory is that turns into
reality
just watch the camera reel in slow
motion it plays out in in dangerously
boring form this is how this is how the
sausage gets made so certainly that was
the first Catalyst and so what began as
a challenge to the system which is you
know as an intellectual or whatever I
always I always enjoy it if I agree it
or not it's at least interesting to
watch something that began as a
challenge to the system stakeholder
capitalism and ESG
slowly became ossified as the system and
there's a lot of forces behind that the
rise of passive index funds played a big
role and that's a discussion I can get
into another another time or maybe later
in this discussion but a big then
Catalyst came out in there was two big
catalysts that came out one was in 2016
and one was in 2018. the thing that
happened in 2016 of course is that
Donald Trump was elected president of
the United States
this created a seismic shock wave Across
The Establishment class both in capital
markets as well as the linkage between
business and politics and when they said
okay wait a minute this game may not be
played the way it's supposed to be going
forward if business if political leaders
like Donald Trump are going to break the
system then we The Business Leaders need
to exercise our authority to step into
the void instead and then they were
Vindicated or so they thought when Trump
pulled out of the Paris climate Accords
in 2018 not a lot of people realize this
that was a big event that is the event
that threw kerosene on this ESG storm
and you know even the people who are
complaining about the CSG movement need
to understand where it came from a
little bit better than they do this was
a big deal so this is what then caused
Calpers the California teachers and
pension retirement system and other big
allocators the people who give BlackRock
and State Street your money they started
to say that look
if political leaders are not going to
step up to the occasion to address the
existential challenges we face like
global climate change then Business
Leaders need to do it instead Larry Fink
the CEO of BlackRock started saying
similar things that we have to earn our
social license to operate and that's
really what caused this ESG thing to
spread like wildfire was that event of
pulling out of the Paris climate Accords
tie the corporate response to say Occupy
Wall Street at the end of the 2008
financial crisis with the climate
catastrophe and so so let's talk about
the climate catastrophe for a moment or
two because and also to find stakeholder
capitalism because the uh the The
Narrative that's insisted upon by the
wolf left let's say but also by these
well capitalists is that the emergency
that confronts us on the environmental
uh Frontier is so cataclysmic that any
and all emergency measures are
thoroughly not only thoroughly Justified
but morally required now I have a
problem with that theory psychologically
as well as technically and so
psychologically
I've been trying to think figure out how
you separate the wheat from the chaff on
the leadership front especially in the
face of an emergency a real emergency
because emergencies do occur from time
to time
but here's a rule of thumb everyone
who's listening can see him try this out
for themselves and see what they think
but
if the emergency you're confronting
terrifies you
so badly that you're paralyzed into
immobility or tempted to aggregate all
the power to yourself and become a
tyrant then you have defined yourself as
insufficient for the job you should be
able to maintain a calm head regardless
of the impending emergency because
there's going to be emergencies and if
you become a tyrant during an emergency
then you're a tyrant and so and then so
that's the psychological issue even if
there is an emergency we shouldn't be
aggregating power into an elite and then
there's a second element too which is
yeah what bloody emergency precisely you
know I've talked a lot to Bjorn lomberg
for example and many other people I
would say as informed as lomberg and
there's no evidence even in the ipcc
reports themselves that climate change
is uh first of all entirely man-made
because it's not and second even if it
is there is no evidence whatsoever the
ipcc reports that there's going to be
some apocalyptic turning point in the
next 50 years that justifies Untold
trillions of panic dollars being spent
well we simultaneously destabilize our
power grids and increase the cost of
electricity by up to five times and make
ourselves at least in Europe much more
reliable or much more
reliant on Russia and also throw poor
people into poverty and risk the fossil
fuel infrastructure that feeds half the
planet because people actually also
don't understand that ammonia is made
out of fossil fuel and ammonia
fertilizer feeds four billion people and
so so so anyways you said 2008 Wall
Street is guilty because of the bailouts
the lefties pushed them hard on the
ethical front and rightly so they decide
to turn to ESG but then that's also
Amplified by this sense of apocalyptic
climate doom and so what's your
formulation of the environmental
challenge that confronts challenges that
confront us now how do you construe that
says I have more to say about the ESG
story but I gotta I gotta yeah you just
said I just got to pause on what you
just said it was really some really good
stuff in there okay so
so you you I just need to go I'm gonna
go one step further than you and draw a
linkage between the psychological
critique and the technical critique
because they're related right so the
first thing you said was a humble and
Powerful point which is even if there is
some sort of existential apocalyptic
issue you should not want to entrust the
people who are going to then wield
tyrannical Force to address it not to
mention the fact that the technical
issue is itself a completely artificial
one right it is grounded on false
premises that deserve to be called out
and I can call those out Bjorn Lundberg
Alex Epstein others can call them out we
can we can go into all the details of
that
but the point I want to make is that
those two critiques that you just
offered spot on as they are are deeply
linked
and the reason is you were almost too
charitable in that psychological account
in that actually the psychological
account explains the fact that the
entire climate agenda
actually has nothing to do with the
climate it's not like this was a
tyrannical response to a threat it was
the creation of an artificial threat to
exercise tyrannical power itself okay
it's a religious cult and so so I said
this numerous times I think the I think
the climate religion has about as much
to do with the climate as the Spanish
Inquisition had to do with Christ which
is to say nothing at all it was really
just about power and dominion and
Punishment all the way down and I can I
can basically prove to you in a short
amount of time right if the climate
religion do it really I mean just just
I'm gonna to avoid going on for hours
I'll just pick a couple of tidbits but
but we could go on for hours but the
couple tidbits we can just start with
are
so so one is if you really care about
carbon emissions as the end-all be-all
okay first of all you'd be delineating
which kind of carbon emissions matter I
I don't subscribe to the tenets of this
religion but I understand this religion
I think it's worth understanding a
religion even if you're not a
practitioner even if you subscribe to
this religion there's a difference
between methane leakage and carbon
dioxide well methane leakage is far
worse in places like Russia and China so
then it should be a mystery that you
want to shift carbon production from the
United States where you tell companies
like Exxon and Chevron to stop producing
to places like China like Petro China on
the other side of the world yeah and by
the way this is exactly what the ESG
movement it's like the Apostles of this
church right so BlackRock is like an
apostle of this Spanish
inquisition-style Church BlackRock
forces companies like Exxon and Chevron
to drop oil production to meet Net Zero
standards by 2050. yet literally some of
the same companies buying up those same
projects on the other side of the planet
are Petro China who BlackRock is a large
shareholder of without telling Petro
China to adopt any of those same
emissions caps this is nuts if you think
that you care about reducing carbon
emissions and it's not even as I was
alluding to methane emissions before
it's not even net neutral methane even
if you subscribe to this crazy religion
is 80 times worse for global warming
then carbon dioxide so it's not even net
neutral it's worse so that's the first
breadcrumb that there's something else
going on here
the second breadcrumb that there's
something else going on here is that
that same movement certainly it's
Apostles in the ESG movement that are so
hostile to carbon emissions
is also hostile to the best known form
of carbon free energy production known
to mankind which is nuclear energy yeah
right so that's the second little
breadcrumb that suggests there's
something else going on here and the
problem with nuclear energy in a
nutshell is that nuclear energy might be
too good at solving the alleged clean
energy problem such that it doesn't
solve for the actual agenda which is
delivering Equity between the West
America in particular and the rest of
the world to catch up that's really what
this club deliveries are delivering and
delivering that power that we've been
talking about of course in terms of the
proper relate the grand Inquisition well
those are the time right so that's
really what's going on
those are two stunning points and I want
to lay them out uh philosophically for a
moment just so people get what this
means completely so let's say that we do
buy the propositions of the of what
Vivek has been calling the climate
religion we'll get back to that term
later so if we do buy that then we're
going to make the assumption that the
fundamental existential crisis facing us
is one of pollution and that that can be
reduced in complexity to carbon dioxide
emission and maybe methane and a couple
of other greenhouse gases now I don't
accept any of that and I know you don't
as well but we'll give the devil is due
if that's actually the driving Factor
then the fundamental uh all fundamental
actions and perceptions should be
directed towards minimizing let's say
carbon dioxide output but the first
point you make is well we're making it
very difficult for Western countries to
use coal and to explore for fossil fuels
but we're making it very easy for China
to do so and since we all share the same
atmosphere and China and other you know
terribly governed countries have way
worse environmental regulations they're
not even in the same universe all we're
doing is substituting a relatively clean
fossil fuel for relatively filthy fossil
fuel and then you know you added that
additional decoration which is well
isn't it also convenient that companies
like Black Rock happen to own huge
shares in exactly the Chinese companies
whose interests they're promoting and so
you know that that's kind of so what
that means is that by the measurement
standards of The Advocates of the
climate religion themselves their
policies are not only a failure they're
actually positively counterproductive
just like they have been in Germany in
the UK and then and that's like that's a
subtle mystery on the fossil fuel front
but then you have the blatant mystery
which is the second thing you post you
you pointed to which is okay boys and
girls we can pretty much solve the
bloody carbon dioxide problem like
overnight with nuclear and yes we have
small nuclear plants now and we have
nuclear plants that are way safer than
they were 50 years ago and that could be
built at a modular level and so why do
you oppose them and well that's that
brings us into the religious issue I
would say because this is not so much a
pro
Planet agenda designed to bring about
harmony with the natural world as it is
an attempt to simultaneously destabilize
the entire industrial infrastructure or
in accordance with the claim that all
human activity is nothing but you know
cancerous growth on the planet combined
with this underground desire to accrue
all tyrannical power into centralized
Elite hands that's exactly right so okay
so with that let's talk about you you've
insisted a number of times that the
climate narrative is a religious or
quasi-religious structure so why don't
you I've got some thoughts about that
which I'll share eventually but I would
like you to lay out why you use that
terminology specifically yeah so I I
mean that in two senses worse is the
sense in which it is a religious
institution gone awry and then the
second is in which it fills the
psychological need for religion and God
in the everyday person on the first of
those just as you were laying out the
philosophical framing of it I was
reminded of actually one of my favorite
stories about Christ actually which came
from not the Bible but from fyodor
dostoyevsky's book uh the brothers
karamazov Brothers gay uh in his chapter
entitled The Grand Inquisitor actually
and it tells the story of how Christ
comes back to Earth during the 15th or
16th century or whatever in Seville
Spain he's walking the streets
performing Miracles and then the grand
Inquisitor a person leading the Spanish
Inquisition spots him on the street and
has him arrested and the whole climax of
the chapter is the dialogue between
Christ and the grand Inquisitor and with
the grand Inquisitor tells Christ is
look we the church don't need you here
anymore you are supposed to be a symbol
that helps us do our work but your
presence here actually stops us from
getting our work done and he sentences
Christ to execution the next morning
Swap and climate for Christ which really
is what's happening in the psychological
minds of people who are buying this
religion of which I'll get to in a
second but that's also what's going on
here is the climate's just an excuse and
in fact once you get into a discussion
about actually addressing carbon
emissions say with nuclear energy they
get very worried so they're sentencing
nuclear energy to death because that's
their Messiah and their savior right you
said you wanted to actually get rid of
carbon emissions well you would you
would welcome the second coming of
Christ the second coming of the climate
solution of nuclear energy no no they
sentence it to death because as the
grand Inquisitor told Christ in that
story your presence here actually
impedes our work you're just supposed to
be a symbol for us so in a certain sense
it has a religious quality in terms of
the church that protects its own turf
even from the very God that it tells
it's it's you know parishioners to
worship now the second question though
is why are the parishioners worshiping
at all and I think this gets to the
heart of in a weird way my candidacy for
president of the United States even
though we're in deep philosophical
terrain here I just think we're in the
middle of this identity crisis where we
are so hungry for
for purpose and meaning and identity As
Americans at a moment it's probably true
for much of the western world too even
Beyond America but we're so hungry for a
cause at a moment in our history when
the things that used to fill that void
faith is one of them faith in God is a
big one but patriotism is also a big one
national identity is big family is also
pretty big in this category
even hard work actually we can get into
that later but these are sources of
identity sources of Pride sources of
grounding they're grounded in truth and
the way I look at us as human beings I
mean this is the first personal
reflection right we're just we're like
blind bats we're lost in some cave in an
abyss and we send out these sonar
signals for our echolocation of identity
right we we can't see where we are but
we deduce where we are by bouncing off
the signals we send and get them back as
sources of Truth okay I send a signal
out family is one source of identity I
get back God is another source of
identity I get back my nation is another
source of identity I get back my hard
work the things I create in the world
these things we deduce our identity and
it tells us even though we're blind
where we are lost in that Abyss but when
those things disappear
we send out that signal
and then nothing comes back
and then we're lost and so then we start
grasping at artificial sources of that
identity racial identity gender identity
what do you think this was bizarre
gender ideology happens to have Arisen
from
climate disaster catastrophism that's a
source of identity two climate instead
of Christ and so it's no accident that
we see all of these secular religions
Arise at the same time why do we see
wokism at the same time as we see
radical gender ideology racial orchism
is gender Radiology as climatism as
covetism
it's a symptom of that deeper Abyss that
we're lost in and so okay so
now you broke this out in two ways you
said I'm going to walk through your
argument you said there's an offer on
hand from above so to speak from the ESG
and climate ideologues but but there's a
an also corresponding need in the
population that's associated with the
kind of emptiness yes and so okay and
then you also talked about the brothers
karamazov and the notion of of the grand
inquisitors so
I want to address all three of those
points so the first point is that the
developmental psychologist John Piaget
pointed out that the last stage of
cognitive development as far as he was
concerned was uh adolescent messianism
and what he meant by that was that
people between the ages of 16 to 21 when
they're they're undergoing their last
great neural uh uh pruning by the way
they sort of settle into their adult
adult identities they have to catalyze
them and the way that human beings
catalyze their adult identity is by
identifying with something Beyond
themselves
and so in a in the archaic situation
that would be with tribe for example but
also with the traditions of the tribe
right rather than just the people that
are there presently now with the ancient
traditions of the tribe and they'll be
initiated into that now there's a
Messianic urge that comes along with
that which could be expressed would be
expressed in modern terms as something
like the desire of young people to to
save the planet okay so that's a true
psychological hunger now what's
ought being offered by the radical left
uh to address that Messianic need is
something like it's very very simple and
this is part of the problem it's like
well to be Christ to be the Messiah you
have to face down the apocalypse right
that's the last judgment the apocalypse
that currently confronts us is
environmental you know and environmental
apocalypses have confronted us
throughout the entire history of mankind
so we have a an ecological what would
you say a psychological predisposition
to be alerted to Environmental Okay so
there's an apocalypse it's environmental
the environmental apocalypse is a
consequence of carbon carbon is a
consequence of excess industrial output
if you adopt the radical left ideology
which is anti-industrial then you you
fulfill your Messianic mission
now that's on the positive side the
negative side is well you can also do
with absolutely no effort on your part
because all you have to do is oppose the
right things
and it also lifts the moral burden from
your shoulders because instead of having
to undergo a psychological
transformation that would
that would involve confrontation of all
of your own inadequacies let's say to
put yourself on the right path
spiritually you can just demonize
whoever happens to be convenient for
demonization and in the radical left
case it would be anything to do with the
industrial or corporate world and you
can put all the sins on the scapegoat's
shoulders and you're done with them and
so that's that's an expanded vision of
that mess ionism right it's this
overwhelmingly simple solution to a very
complex moral problem all right now on
the identity front
you laid out a bunch of issues that I
think are extremely relevant so you know
that people are struggling with their
identities and what's happened is
they're also being offered a one idea
fits all problems solution which is
while your identity is nothing other
than your group identity it's your
sexual proclivity which is a pretty
pathetic identity it's your ethnicity
it's your race it's some group identity
which also takes the responsibility off
of you by the way now you might say well
what constitutes a valid identity in
contrast to that and you've already
pointed to a number of those things so
this is also where I think the
psychological Community has failed to a
large degree on this front now
were The Heirs of a liberal Protestant
tradition
socially and psychologically and we
believe that our identities are
fundamentally individual and subjective
okay but that's actually not true
because your identity is nested now you
pointed so let's think of nestings okay
because we could build a hierarchy
that's a proper hierarchy conceptually
and this is this is a good way of
formulating what actually constitutes a
robust identity this is where you'd get
signal for those
for those uh you know those forays that
you're putting out those signals exactly
okay so look a person has to be bound
into an intimate relationship and
everybody needs and wants that so that's
the first level of social integration
and then the the couple has to be
integrated within a family
and then the family within a
neighborhood and the neighborhood within
a community and the community with it in
a town a town within the state the state
within a nation and then the nation
let's say into something approximating
whatever web of international agreements
is necessary to minimally keep the peace
that's a subsidiary hierarchy of
responsibility
you know and in Exodus in the Old
Testament book Exodus part of what that
book addresses is what forms of
governance are necessary as an
alternative to tyranny so single
top-down tyranny the Pharaoh or the
desert which is you know completely
scattered individuality and the answer
is the technical answer is the
subsidiary hierarchy of responsibility
and so that means you know as an
individual you have a responsibility as
a couple as a family member as a
community member and all of those and
then you can think of identity
as the belonging in all of those
hierarchical positions and you can think
of psychological Health not as something
that occurs in in an interior space but
as the harmony between all of those
subsidiary levels so it's an emergent
property of Harmony and not something
that's carried internally
hey Reagan I know you're picky when it
comes to skin care products so tell me
what did you think of genucel skin care
exactly right Garrett I'm the type of
person who needs to know exactly what
ingredients I'm using in my skincare
routine which is why I'm loving genucel
their products are made with
antioxidants and formulated by a
compounding pharmacist and they're all
about preventative skin care I've been
using genucel's new microbiome
moisturizer to Target skin redness fine
lines and other signs of premature aging
it uses the same probiotics that are in
your yogurt as it turns out these super
ingredients can have the same nourishing
benefits on your skin as they do to your
digestive system the results have been
incredible my skin cleared up within
hours genuso has a product for every
skin type and it's not just for us girls
I got started with their most popular
package which includes all their best
sellers bundled into one amazing price
you heard it here first go to
genyourself.com Jordan to get 70 off
their most popular package that's
genucel.com Jordan genucel.com Jordan
[Music]
I I love I mean this is this is
beautiful stuff actually and and when
you just describe the desert versus
Pharaoh uh Dynamic out there the
separation something clicked for me okay
yeah well it's a killer set of ideas
well even in a much more practical sense
for me to you know something as mundane
as a political race here okay it clicks
for me why I'm doing this is that yeah
you're right you and I and others like
us have complained about how the left
has actually preyed on that vacuum by at
least offering a substantive even if
false fundamentally artificial set of
identities to fill that void
but actually I'm sick of complaining
about that without critiquing the
conservative movement where's the
conservative movement in filling its
that identity with an alternative right
we can ring or we can do all the hand
ringing we want where are we over the
last 10 years where's our leadership
where's the leadership of for example
conservative movement pro-american
movement pro-national movement Pro
family movement whatever you want to
call it these guys have been asleep at
the switch while they've been watching
the other side take advantage of this
and that that kind of or or well not
just that it's worse than that like if
you're participating in it in some ways
they're participating well it's the
conservatives it's the conservatives in
the UK who've been putting forward the
Net Zero agenda so exactly so so you
know so especially especially in Western
Europe but even some wings of the
Republican Party in the U.S are their
Meek response is effectively effectively
participating in this and this is where
the analogy that hit me when you're
talking about the desert and Pharaoh is
that
we as a people are lost in the desert
and yet we're criticizing that
phenomenon by still critiquing Pharaoh
well the Israelites already go many of
them are already gone okay that's where
a lot of the Grassroots movement that
I'm leading already and hoping to lead
is we're already in the desert we're
still lost though we're not going to
find the Promised Land by still
criticizing pharaoh to the contrary the
longer you're lost the longer the more
likely it is the people are going to say
that I need to go back and bend the knee
to Pharaoh actually I want to be ruled
by Pharaoh that's exactly what's
happening so so where is the promised
land and you know I'm not I'm not gonna
you know this analogy is related to a
weird place I'm not going to claim to be
a Moses figure or anything like that
that's beyond beyond any of our pay
grade but I will say you know when I
laid out in this room the video where we
launched this presidential campaign from
right here in the front foyer of my
house
we said that my goal is to create a new
American Dream for the 21st century okay
FDR had his new deal I don't agree with
a lot of it but FDR had his new deal JFK
had his new frontier
where's the conservative vision of where
we're going that's what I call the new
dream the new American Dream it's not
just about money yeah it's about
Reviving our conviction in our purpose
as Citizens what does that mean
Unapologetic pursuit of Excellence I can
talk about what that means but but
that's my vision maybe a different
candidate can offer theirs and if this
Republican primary ended up being a
competition of those ideas and Visions
man our country's head into a good place
but that's what's missing yes definitely
well okay so let's let's talk about the
conservative issue here for a minute so
if you look at what temperamental uh
factors predict
political allegiance that the literature
on that's quite clear if you're higher
in openness if you're hiring creativity
and you're low in conscientiousness you
tend to
move to the radical left let's say if
you're high in conscientiousness and low
in openness you tend to move towards the
conservative front and there's a
there's a constant dialogue between
those extremes because the creative
people are necessary to make changes
when changes are necessary but dangerous
otherwise and the conservative types are
very good at maintaining functional
tradition but are intransigent in the
face of necessary change and so free
speech is actually the mechanism by
which that conundrum is mediated because
people who can engage in free speech can
keep arguing about which Traditions need
to be carefully modified okay so but
here's the problem that it presents on
the conservative front so conservatives
are not Visionaries by definition The
Visionaries tend to tilt in the more
radical Direction because they have
radical Visions you know and and so the
conservatives are always pushed back
into a reactionary standpoint almost
always they they object vociferously to
the excesses of the left but because
they're not Visionary they can't extract
from their tradition an image of the
promised land for the future now and
I've been working with an organization
in the UK that's trying to do something
that's analogous to what you're doing to
to lay out something approximating a
compelling Vision on the conservative
side you know I'll I'll talk about one
part of it sure because I think it
strikes right to the core even of what
we're discussing so we spent a lot of
time talking about families
because
so you have the individual then you have
the individual in a couple but the next
order of subsidiary organization is
family
and then you might ask yourself well
what is a family now
the the answer on the inclusive left is
a family is any old organization of any
sort but that's
that's so blurry that it leaves people
with no guidelines they don't know what
to do because if you can do anything you
have no direction and so well we could
say well a family a family fundamentally
is a unit that produces children
and
and if you're not willing to buy that
definition well then you could go
develop your own definition of family
but it seems to me that there's
something core about laying the
groundwork for the emergence and proper
rearing of children that's key to what
constitutes a family and then one of the
corollaries of that is well if you're
going to have children you're probably
going to need to have a man and a woman
involved
otherwise it's extremely well it's very
difficult otherwise and that actually
turns out to be relevant when you're
thinking about an ideal so I talked to
Dave Rubin about this for example so
Reuben who's conservative and gay is
married to his his partner his husband
Dave and they went through the entire
surrogacy route to have a couple of
infants and it was very very very very
very very complicated both ethically
practically and financially and so and
they managed it so far you know they
have these two kids and I suspect
they'll do a perfectly good job of
giving these kids a wonderful home but
they're also incredibly financially uh
what would you say privileged you know
Dave's earned it but they have the
capital to make this non-standard
solution of possibility
but it's by no means duplicatable for
the typical person I mean the simplest
way to have a child for the average
person is to have man and a woman
involved and you can use technological
intermediaries but it can't propagate
easily that solution and so one of the
things that's emerged this is extremely
interesting one of the things that's
emerged on the cognitive Neuroscience
front recently and the same things
happened in the field of AI is the
realization that at the center of all of
our Concepts
is an ideal that's actually how we
categorize we categorize just like Plato
initially uh hypothesized we CA we
literally categorize in relationship to
an implicit ideal I think so to even use
to even use the term family and in it
for that to be meaningful there has to
be an ideal and the organization that
I've started working with and helping
put together has
made it uh what part of our formal
propositional landscape that the ideal
has to be something like stable
long-term monogamous heterosexual
child-centered couples
and now the problem with the ideal this
is what the postmodernists have shaken
their fists about forever especially the
French like daradu and Foucault the
problem with the ideal is that it
marginalizes
right because the more distant you are
from the ideal the less you can fit in
and so the question then arises what do
you do with the margin and that's that
that's also a question that's so old
that that was even dealt with in
biblical times by the way the problem of
The Fringe or the margin and the answer
has to be something like look
everybody falls short of the ideal
like even a married stable married
heterosexual couple lots of the times
during their say 30-year marriage
they're going to fight they're going to
wish they were divorced they're going to
wish they were with other partners there
might be Affairs lots of people end up
divorced there's there's the vast
majority of us will never
realize the idea well none of us will in
in totality but that doesn't mean we
should sacrifice the ideal what it means
is that we should put forth the ideal
forthrightly but allow the necessary
space for deviation from the ideal so
that everybody can move forward despite
the fact that the ideal has to rule it's
a great great framing I just want to
jump in there for one second to draw
even one further distinction if I may is
first is there's the sense in which each
of us falls short of our ideals okay
both as individuals and even as a nation
I mean you could extrapolate this to the
American level and you know take the
critique of America as a nation is that
while America is hypocritical right it
had Nations that set an emotion but
there were slaves on day one Ergo the
ideals themselves are false No in fact
hypocrisy is probably pretty good
evidence that you have ideals right
there's no sense in which for example
the Chinese Communist Party could be
called hypocritical you can't be called
hypocritical if you actually are
measured against fundamentally nihilism
at your core so idealism and the
existence of ideals makes hypocrisy
possible we should be grateful when we
see hypocrisy because then we know we
have two things we have both ideals and
we have something that is real and
something that is real never matches or
rarely ever matches the ideals so there
in a certain sense we should be we
should we should be Vindicated we should
feel reassured that we're we're doing
something right because we have both
ideals in reality and that's just true
at the individual level of anybody who's
in a married relationship knows this if
they don't admit it they're lying to you
or they're lying to themselves it's just
it's just truth okay
I think that that is still distinct from
a second question that you raised which
is also a good question which is I think
what
what and I'm a big fan of taking the
best arguments we possibly can to
understand you know what we're what
we're you know taking seriously here
is is the marginal point is is who's at
the outer end of the margin and there I
think some of this relates to not just a
failure of an individual temporally over
the course of a lifetime to depart from
the ideal but some ways in which a
certain person cannot themselves be part
of the ideal ever because their genetics
are real right the what brings us into
this world Israel the the gender be it
sexual orientation be it other
attributes that that make one successful
or not in a system that's set up in a
certain way
there is literally a reality of
permanent marginalization for some even
according to an ideally structured
system and so I think it's important to
take that seriously but the problem with
the modern left the modern radical left
is it turns that
exercise of
interrogating the question of what we do
at the margin and makes a whole new
system out of it right what began as a
challenge to the system on behalf of the
marginalized becomes the new system that
is the essence of the woke cancer
actually I didn't mind it when it was an
idea in in the halls of a liberal arts
academy to think about at least debate
how it is we accommodate the people who
are marginalized in a system that is
still an ideal system that's an open
conversation that at least under
parameters of free speech which as you
said is an intermediating mechanism
between kind of the the creative
liberals and the and the you know what
was the juxtaposition to creative uh
cards conscience conscientious
conservatives that's great but as long
as we have Free Speech but the problem
is when that challenge to the system
becomes the new system we're then
heading to a very different place than
even the ideal that okay pro-marginal
would have argued for okay well so so we
can lay it out a little bit too what
happened to Nicola sturgeon is a perfect
example of that the prime minister of
Scotland who just resigned because
here's the problem with the Fringe okay
so the the ideal in the center is a
Unity it's a single thing
The Fringe is a multiplicity now the
problem with the Fringe is that because
it's a multiplicity it can't occupy the
center without destroying the ideal and
that just brings the whole category to a
to collapse The Fringe Of The Fringe
will destroy The Fringe that's right so
yeah so we can't do without the ideal
even though I love I love I love what
you I mean the The Fringe defines itself
in relation to the ideal right in a dark
sense but it has Freedom it also has
freedom because exactly it's like the
freedom of being at the margin because
because there's many versions of being
at the front it's kind of like that lost
bat analogy you send your your sonar
signal it bounces back and says this is
where you are it's like planets orbiting
the Sun all right once the sun's gone
you're just you're you're there's going
to be a whole new there's going to be a
whole new structure around you that's
exactly what happens and sometimes I
think conservatives they'll use this
phrase right they'll come to eat their
own right and and and I think that that
there's a point to that but it's low
resolution I mean the essence of what's
going on is actually what you described
which is that once you've destroyed or
invaded the ideal Itself by definition
being on the fringes is sort of
nihilistic at its core and so at that
point it's a free-for-all which is to
say that okay well you thought you were
On The Fringe as being gay well guess
what you know or if you could do the
feminist you ain't seen nothing yeah you
ain't seen nothing you can see the
feminist version of this too Title IX
women's sports you know women are On The
Fringe well then when that itself
becomes the center of the story you just
wait till you just say that the men
become the women that actually through
the back door decimate the existence of
women's sports not because they weren't
funded pre-title IX but even after
funding the essence of it is gone if
biological men are competing as women
same thing with respect to the with
respect to being gay all of this time to
sort of x accept somebody who is
attracted to someone of a different sex
at Birth by saying that the sex of the
person you're attracted to is hardwired
at Birth right that was the premise of
the gay rights movement and I think
there's a lot of Truth in it too is
completely undercut by a new movement
that says your sex itself is completely
fluid over the course of your lifetime
yeah so so it isn't quite what some
people will say was is they will
eventually eat their own it's the fact
that they've itself lost the structure
against which they at least had the
Liberty to be on The Fringe of right and
so that's not to say that we shouldn't
have you know conversations for you know
disabled people or whatever in the in
the you know American Disabilities Act
context that's what comes up in a
political context there's a there's a
whole discussion to be had about how we
deal with this problem of The Fringe how
we deal with accommodation against the
backdrop of ideals and and I want to be
really clear I I don't dismiss that
conversation in fact I think that should
be the product of dialectic I think Free
Speech can actually be a mechanism for
sorting out those kinds of questions and
I don't reject their importance but I
think that what's happened right now is
the obsession with The Fringe has has
eviscerated the ideal itself which
leaves both those who espouse the ideals
and even those who identified themselves
as one time being a member of a fringe
all worse off in the end and that's
exactly where we are and that's a due to
failure of the conservative movement
it's a failure of the conservative
movement see we can blame the people on
The Fringe for you know getting us there
they were just the agents and the pawns
who moved it but it's the it's the role
of the conservative movement to keep
that structure intact and I think the
absence of to make a case for it and to
make a case for it and so and so so then
then what happens in the evolution of
time now right so now we're in a moment
where
the discussion that you and I have
already are talking about that ship has
sailed the structure itself is gone what
does that require that's what makes this
so difficult and I think that in some
ways you've made a more powerful
philosophical case for my candidacy that
in my first week I have yet to do yet
which is that it requires defying the
odds of having somebody who is both
conscientious conscientious conservative
as you noted but who has the capacity
for being Visionary in having the vision
of recreating that structure that solar
system around which the the rest of the
fringes can orbit
and that's inherently an unlikelihood
but by you said by the psychological
nature of creativity and
conscientiousness those are not supposed
to coincide that's what sets a really
high bar it's also what calls me into
this race because it is what our moment
demands because we're not starting from
neutral territory we're starting from
the state of of you know entropic chaos
that you highlight desert in the desert
not we're not so we're starting from
being lost in the desert and so thank
you because you have in a philosophical
in a deeply philosophically grounded way
made the case for my candidacy and why I
am doing this whether I will not do I
will deliver or not the next year and a
half remains to be told but that's at
least the challenge I'm setting out to
take on and and thank you for laying
that out well with this group that I've
been working with in London we've also
set forward a couple of other
propositions too which is that if your
policy requires compulsion or Force it's
at least sub-optimal and so we're trying
to play an Invitational game and so you
could imagine that on the Visionary
Horizon your goal as if Visionary is to
produce an image that's so compelling
that people of their own free Accord say
yeah you know I'd be willing to
sacrifice to that end yes yes willing to
sacrifice it I I love the way you frame
that because because you can you can
make a sacrifice if you know what you
are sacrificing for actually so this was
a big part of my upbringing right in
immigrant parents from India Hindu
tradition came to this country
part and parcel of parenting part and
parcel of growing up as a kid in that
household the idea of sacrifice was
woven into my upbringing right
grandparents who lived in the house
because it was their duty to take care
of their parents because that was just
familial sacrifice needed to be made
sacrifices needed to be made to raise my
brother and I to have the academic
achievements that we did in the
education that didn't happen in a vacuum
it happened on the back of parents who
actually said there's more to life than
just following your latest
self-indulgence but these yeah these
things can be done if you know what
you're sacrificing for
I draw that as analogy to some of my
policy agenda this is a harder sell but
I think it's true too in the United
States today needs to I've made the case
declare independence from China that's a
whole separate geopolitical discussion
we can have why I think that's important
why I think there's an opportunity but
also been even in week one very clear
this will involve some measure of
sacrifice in fact if there's some
resistance I'm getting to the
Declaration of Independence proposition
of China it's actually coming from some
Republicans who are unwilling to make
that sacrifice who have become so
addicted to buying cheap stuff but again
I say that we can make those sacrifices
if we know what we are sacrificing for
and so this idea of sacrifice I think is
fundamental to this question of identity
once you're grounded in identity once
you're grounded in who you are and what
you might be willing to make a sacrifice
for it's almost a litmus test for
identity if you have nothing that you're
willing to make a sacrifice for it means
you have no identity right and so that's
a great framing of it
looking for an all-in-one e-commerce
platform that can help you easily set up
and grow your business online look no
further than Shopify with Shopify you
can quickly and easily build your own
online store manage your inventory and
accept payments from customers plus
Shopify offers a range of customizable
themes and templates to choose from so
you can create a professional looking
store without any design experience it
even helps integrate with other popular
tools to help you sell across social
media marketplaces like Tick Tock
Facebook and Instagram with shopify's 24
7 support and an extensive Business
course library that is available to
support you every step of the way
Shopify is the Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide if you're ready to get serious
about selling try Shopify today sign up
for a one dollar per month trial period
at shopify.com jbp go to shopify.com jvp
to take your business to the next level
today that's shopify.com jbp
[Music]
let's go down that road for a moment so
because you you might you might ask
yourself well why use the sacrificial
language and also why do you need to
make sacrifices at all and the answer is
you're always going to be making
sacrifices because if you do one thing
instead of another then you sacrifice
all the other things you could have done
so there's no action whatsoever without
sacrifice now then you might ask well is
there actually something in reality
that's worth sacrificing for and the
answer is well first of all you don't
have a choice now generally what because
no matter what you do if you do
something you're sacrificing now people
might say well I want to be able to do
whatever I want whenever I want and so
that's sort of the ultimate in
subjectivity and there's an
impulsiveness and a and a pandering to
whim that's associated with that but
that's not really Freedom what that is
is subjection to the rule by impulsive
whims exactly you see as characterizing
chill
why sacrifice that and the answer is
because it isn't a coherent or communal
medium to long-term solution the reason
you sacrifice the whims of childhood
that polytheistic state of motivational
possession that characterizes childhood
the reason you sacrifice that to an
integrated maturity is because the
integrated maturity a constitutes an
identity that will protect you from
anxiety and provide you with hope but
also unifies you across time and lays
the preconditions for your social
integration and there's nothing about
that that's arbitrary and so the
question isn't who is going to rule you
no I want no one to rule how can I set
my life up so no one can rule me the
question is what is it that I'm going to
work towards allowing to rule me and
it's either going to be my whims
which means I'm subject to them or it's
going to be some higher order state of
integration that requires sacrifice and
then that ties into this whole
hierarchical identity you know you
sacrifice your whims to your partner you
and your partner sacrifice your whims to
your children yes your family sacrifices
its whims to the community and all of
that now you want that to be done
harmoniously and you want it to be done
voluntary autonomously voluntarily
exactly yes exactly yeah so so so so we
had to create that sense of identity and
purpose that makes us voluntarily opt
into that nested identity state right
there is there's a sacrifice for
marriage exactly right there is a
sacrifice to entering a marriage it's a
sacrifice for making there's a sacrifice
to having children that's a sacrifice
worth making there is a sacrifice to
being a citizen of a Nation I'm not a
global citizen just a global I'm a
citizen of a Nation there's a sacrifice
worth making we can make these
sacrifices if we know what's worth
sacrificing for that's the missing what
I call them the conservative movement to
borrow from David Hume David Hume had
this famous chapter in in uh in sort of
his his uh he was an empiricist but one
of the paradoxes in his theory of
empiricism was what he called the
missing shade of blue he could say what
the shade of blue was without having
ever having seen it that was a challenge
to his theory of empiricism anyway I
borrowed that I call it the missing
shade of red in the conservative
movement is this idea of the Revival of
Duty and embracing Duty as a
precondition for freedom but it's Duty
that we actually autonomously opt into
by way of our free choice and our Free
Will these things are not incompatible
they're not contradictory they sound
contract not at all they're not police
they're sort of mutually required the
other thing I was just going to say
about kids because I think this is one
where I wasn't sure if you were going to
disagree with me on this but actually
having heard you I suspect that you
don't I've gotten this actually a lot on
the road I was in Iowa New Hampshire
last week
a lot of distinction between this idea
of freedom and autonomy amongst adults
versus in children so you know one of
the things that I've said that rankles I
think a lot of the you know libertarian
leading you know conservatives or
whatever and I used to call myself a
Libertarian for a bunch of reasons I'm
not anymore
but you know is this idea that children
are different than adults okay and so
that period you talked about between 16
and 21. I mean let's I'll just even take
the the easier end of the spectrum
forget 21 just say 16.
if you can't use an addictive cigarette
by the age of 18 or drink a an addictive
sip of alcohol by the age of 21. why is
it that you're allowed to use an
addictive social media product as a
pre-teen either I mean that at the very
least is an inconsistency in the way we
treat this now I I fully agree with you
that all else equal the path to getting
to this ideal the structure of Ideal
that we discussed before
ought to be a path that does not involve
coercion or impinging on Free Will it is
uh you you phrased it very politely it
would be sub-optimal I believe is the
word you used I think that that is the
most gracious way of of putting that I
think it should be avoided is the way I
would say it as a as a prospective
policy maker and leader of the country
but I don't apply the same rules of the
road as it applies to children because
none of us believe that children
actually uh you know children actually
should be treated as the same autonomous
agents that they ought to be on the
other side of entering adulthood now
that gets into questions of parenting
Etc which we can get into but be that as
it may I I buy into this I buy into this
uh vision of
structure as necessary in a precondition
for experience of freedom but the path
to getting there can't involve coercion
I'm with you all the way so so in The
Exodus story
when God
charges Moses with standing up to the
pharaoh
he tells Moses to tell he tells Moses to
tell the Pharaoh something very specific
and he has him repeat it 10 times in
case you didn't notice right it's
repeated 10 times in the story nine or
ten times he tells Moses to let my
people go of course a very famous phrase
but that's not the phrase the phrase is
let my people go
so that they may worship or celebrate me
in the wilderness in the desert and so
what it does is it sets up not freedom
but ordered freedom
and so then you might ask yourself well
what constitutes ordered Freedom well a
game is ordered Freedom a voluntary game
is ordered freedom because you have a
large landscape of choice but it's
dependent on principles right those are
the rules of the game and a game is a
good analogy because people play games
voluntarily
and they want to play them and they
enjoy them and so if you said something
like if you set up social structure up
with a game like uh substructure then
people voluntarily hop aboard now the
free market responds to the problem of
the margins is to produce a plethora of
games
and so that you might be a margin you
might be marginal in one game or almost
all games but there may be some game
that you'll be Central because of your
temperamental advantages and I think you
can see that in the gay community for
example especially among male
homosexuals because the entertainment
industry especially on the on that on
the more explicitly cultural end is
dominated by male by gay men and there's
a reason for that as far as I'm
concerned because male homosexuality is
associated with heightened levels of
creativity and so there it there's a
margin there and the margin is well if
you're creative you're not going to be
traditional it's going to be hard for
you to abide by the ideal but there's a
niche for you on the cultural
transformation front and so a free
market solution to
um the problem of marginalization is
something like that the offering of a
true diversity it's like yeah you're
only five foot two so you can't play
basketball you know but you might be a
damn good jockey exactly we have enough
games exactly exactly that and then
people can trade on their idiosyncrasies
and you see this is an argument that
free market types haven't made to the
diversity types it's like well the
reason you want a free market is to
provide a diverse number of games so the
marginalized can find a center diversity
in our approach to diversity Itself by
the way and I think you see the same
thing I mean so I've been trying I don't
know that I've succeeded over the last
several years but I've been trying to
exactly preach that to the diversity
crowd where even if you think about
institutional purpose right you were
talking about the level of individuals
in the marginalized side and so I agree
with that that's one form of diverse
approaches to diversity here's a
different approach to diverse approaches
to diversity is diversity of
institutional purpose that even
different companies let's just take it
in the realm of companies that's the
world I've lived in right Corporate
America and capital markets fine each
company ought to have a unique purpose
and what is the problem with using a
common three-letter acronym it's funny
how these things always come in three
letter acronyms but from ESG to Dei to
CSR to you know CCP I joke around yeah
yeah exactly CCP and Wes are some of the
ones lurking behind the scenes but the
problem with these you know ESG or Dei
three-letter acronyms is what are they
effectively saying they're saying that
no no you can't have your own
distinctive purpose everyone's purpose
must be common to advance environmental
social and governance goals diversity
equity and inclusion goals that's a
denial of diversity right it rejects
exactly it's a lurking tyranny versus if
you're really pro-diversity you should
have that fall out of the structure that
you and I discussed right what is your
institutional purpose if you run an
institution you have one question why do
we exist
period have a good answer to that
question and then say what type of
diversity you espouse that's really just
in service of advancing that
institutional purpose different types of
Institutions should want different kinds
of diversity and and they should be
transparent about what types of
diversity they don't want I'll actually
give you one example that I use that's
sort of funny you know at times is I'm a
vegetarian okay I don't eat meat because
I believe it is in my tradition morally
wrong to kill animals solely for
culinary pleasure there are conditions
in which it would be fine to do it but
if it's just for my culinary pleasure
I'd rather not do it I respect other
people's right to and and freedom to go
in a different direction but
take the example of me working at a
steakhouse okay
I would not make for a good employee at
a steakhouse even if I would deliver the
ever-prized form of diversity of thought
see people sometimes they're loose in
terms of my diversity of thought instead
of diversity of appearance yeah yeah I'm
in favor of diversity of thought over
diversity of appearance too but even
diversity of thought is too low
resolution but that's a diverse thought
but a steakhouse still shouldn't want to
employ me because that's not the kind of
diversity of thought you should want if
your focus is on delivering excellent
stake to a customer because the kind of
diversity you want there should be in
service of your purpose and so I think
this this revival of the idea of purpose
itself gives meaning to diversity itself
and that's whether that's true in a
company context or a national context
that's kind of my approach to to the
diversity discussion that we've we've
managed to obsess over
there's a couple of places we can go
with that so one of the things you're
pointing out and it's in keeping with
this Berkey and notion of subsidiarity
that has its Origins and this Exodus
narrative by the way is that
there's going to be a variety of
Institutions at each level of the
hierarchy so you could imagine there's a
variety of forms of couples you know
there's going to be some couples where
the where the woman is the primary
Breadwinner for example there's going to
be some couples where the man is and and
that's fine you you want the commonality
of the coupling but you want the
diversity of possibilities within that
framework and then the same at the level
of family there's going to be some
families with 10 kids there's going to
be some families with one there's going
to be Blended families but that's that
still circles around the core of family
so you have order but you have diversity
at each of the levels of order and then
you also have the recognition that each
of those levels has its own
domain of
of sacred responsibility
now one of the things I've noticed you
could try this out for yourself if
you're curious about it but you know
I've gone to 400 cities in the last four
years lecturing about the sorts of
things that we're talking about today
and there's one point I make that always
brings the audience no matter where it
is to a dead silence like absolutely pin
drop dead silence and here's the
argument so
you need a sustaining meaning in your
life
now what does sustaining mean
it means it will sustain you through
catastrophe so it'll sustain you through
pain and Terror
now that can't be happiness
because happiness is absent in
conditions of pain and Terror so it
can't be that
so what is it well I drew in my clinical
it experience to answer that question
well what do people have when things
when they're truly in the desert when
they're abandoned and lost and in pain
well they have the structure around them
that they'd made sacrifices to produce
they have their partner
they have their you know their their
wife or their husband they have their
children and their parents and their and
their siblings they have their friends
they have their Community they have this
hierarchy of social structure around
them that can sustain them if they made
the proper sacrifices and then the
question is well what is the nature of
the sacrifice that's necessary to make
those bonds and the answer is well
that's the adoption of voluntary
responsibility and so once you know this
is something conservatives haven't ever
made explicit
the meaning that sustains you in tragedy
is to be found through the voluntary
adoption of responsibility
and so you can tell young people that
it's you can tell young people that you
say they say well why should I grow up I
can just do whatever I want whenever I
want and that's especially true if they
happen to be wealthy and privileged and
the answer is well if you expend all
that capital on Hedonism as soon as the
storms come you're Shipwrecked
absolutely there'll be nothing left of
you because there's no Hedonism in hell
and what you have there is whatever
you've built responsibly and there's
meaning in that and people understand
that immediately and it's part of this
alternative Vision to this fractured
Hedonism that everyone is celebrating
now let me ask you a question about that
um because I think this is really
interesting I mean
and I care about delivering this
solution right so I want to I want to
get to the heart of it
there's two possibilities there and the
answer might be both but I want to get a
sense for which one
you meant
um one is that that sustained meaning is
that what you said sustain purpose me
yeah the sustaining meaning yeah it'll
sustain you across time right sustaining
meaning that that can pre-exist and be
uh resilient across catastrophe in a way
that this this superficial idea of
Happiness tradition does that tradition
can be grounded if you're embedded in a
tradition right you bet right but
there's there's a version of what you
described which also makes me think
about a very different direction here
which is that
also form that in response
to catastrophe two and so I think I
think much of the social structure that
we have created in absence of that
purpose and vacuum I mean this might be
a cycles of history thing less about
psychology and more just about the
nature of History here is that we create
the conditions
for that catastrophe whatever it might
be and it might be that catastrophe
itself may have to be the Catalyst for
rediscovering what that sustained
meaning was across
across those circumstances in the future
be that economic catastrophe I think
that we're due for economic tough times
in part for a lot of the difficult
decisions we've made over the last 10
years amidst this vacuum of purpose I
think China may do this favor favor at
using air quotes for the United States
but but which of those was the sense in
which you meant it right in a vacuum in
first principles developing that to be
resilient across time or are you also
you know subconsciously making some kind
of empirical prediction here that in
absence of this we're going to have to
would have this as a response at least
that will cause us to adapt
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
Scripps memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johann Cooper science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and mid
and science to to civilization itself it
is the most influential book in all of
history and hopefully people can walk
away with at least a sense of that
I would say I would say that you don't
have to think except when you're failing
because the purpose of thinking is to
calculate a new trajectory and if the
trajectory you're you're pursuing is
producing the desired results then your
theory is intact well then the question
emerges which is well how much failure
is necessary to make you think and
that's actually a moral question and
that's a question of willful blindness
you know if you're awake and alert and
if you're humble in the classic virtuous
sense you're always trying to figure out
where you're insufficient and to rectify
that right in many Christian prayers the
Jesus prayer for example is a reminder
that the Orthodox cite that continually
chant out continually is a reminder that
you're insufficient in your current form
and you should be looking for what would
Rectify you that's the practice of
humility and the advantage to that
practice is that you can make micro
repairs instead of staying stubborn
until the apocalypse happens and then
collapsing now in the in the story of
Moses what happens to the Pharaoh who's
a tyrant is that the crisis emerge and
then magnify right they just get worse
and worse and worse and worse and he
utterly failed to respond and the
consequence of that is that his entire
societies is devastated the firstborn
are all killed and the Red Sea floods
and destroys the uh the what the
military might of the Egyptian Empire
and so so the the answer to your
question is
um
what's the relationship between failure
and and a return to
Abiding and sustaining values and the
answer is well it depends on how
stiff-necked you are exactly
stiff-necked enough well if you're
stiff-necked enough and this is no joke
and I mean this if you're stiff-necked
enough then you face the apocalypse
and we're toying with that at the moment
on like that's exactly where we are
that's exactly where we are and I think
that I think that
in certain sense my goal in this journey
is to make sure that that doesn't have
to be the the Catalyst for deliverance
okay well what could that be nice
because if it's not going to be somebody
who delivers a vision but from a from a
actually conservatively grounded
perspective with the conscious justice
of a conservative that still brings a
creativity a vision to this
well then it may gonna it may have to be
done by force by way of Apocalypse
anyway and you know in the modern sense
of that word we're going to have to be
forced to learn the lesson that we
couldn't learn ourselves in the first
place I don't think we're quite there
yet and I do think we have a window to
get this right which is the entire
premise of I mean you have verbalized
using words what I feel in my in my
bones in my heart that compels me to
want to do this
better than I have at any point in the
last week so I've watched
watched many people on the Democrat side
many people on the Republican side and
in different countries as well and this
is what I see happening consistently
so neophytes entered the political Arena
now they may have been people who like
you have had a pretty stellar career and
have racked up enough successes so that
they can present themselves as credible
candidates and you know two thumbs up
for that I I think that's a necessary
precondition but they get intimidated in
the new Arena because the stakes are
super high and they don't have a lot of
experience and so what they end up doing
is they end up hiring communication
teams and there are experts at political
communication and they usually involve
pollsters for example and speech writers
people who will help you craft your
message and then what I see happening
and this is inevitable this is the
inevitable consequence is that the
person running loses their voice and
they often lose the election too by the
way they lose their voice and the
election now not always sometimes they
win but they still lose their voice
so and one of the things that's emerged
is the opportunity on the political
landscape to do what you and I are doing
right now
which is really different you know for
40 years politicians in some sense had
to craft their message because they had
to pass it through the narrow bandwidth
of Legacy Media right and so they'd had
to compress things into a 30-second
sound they were forced to right yeah
right right but now
now you have the opportunity to just say
what you think
and if you just say what you think well
first of all if you're wrong you'll
learn that's useful and the other thing
is is that people are going to respond
positively to that because they're
desperate for truth now you can tell
that because Trump was successful now
I'm not trying to put Trump out you know
on some pedestal up on some pedestal is
the world's greatest truth teller but I
would say that one of the things Trump
did was speak without
without you could say without
forethought but that isn't without
inhibition without inhibition yes yeah
he basically for for all of his flaws he
did he he struck especially the working
class as genuine because he was willing
to say what he thought and what was cool
about that was that he won and so I'm
really interested in your candidacy you
know because you're coming in well from
Left Field you know you're going to
definitely be a dark horse candidate
it's very interesting like God only
knows how that'll play out but one of
the advantages that I think you have
apart from your financial background and
the fact that you're alert to the
dangers of ESG tyranny and so forth
which is a non-trivial example is that
you can really afford to take the risk
you know how to use the new media and
that's a deadly advantage and also you
know your your candidacy is sufficiently
unlikely so that there's no reason for
you to do things in a conventional
manner because conventionally you should
just lose you're not well enough known
right you don't have enough of a
political apparatus I don't have a
machine but you know right so actually
that could be a huge Advantage you know
one of the pieces of help I'll ask for
you is keep me honest through this whole
thing because that's where I'm starting
off I can imagine that there's a lot of
people who Embark with that vision and
then just become stultified by the
suffocating forces around them but I'll
tell you I'll tell you a couple rules of
the road that I've I've you know tied my
hands to the Mast to make this easy for
me in a good way is no one's going to
write another speech for me in fact even
when I get speeches I don't write my own
speeches I just say what's on my mind I
don't use a teleprompter in fact a fun I
haven't I haven't said this yet a fun
little challenge I was thinking about
issuing to the entire Republican field
maybe I'll just do it right now is don't
have anyone write your speeches and
don't use a teleprompter I'll make that
commitment why doesn't the whole field
make that commitment no teleprompter I
speak from the heart get it out there
and you know one of the things that
we're going to do is I've learned pretty
early on what you're supposed to do if
you're running for president is you get
trained behind closed doors and then
people train you and prep you with your
talk points and you come on put on this
nice suit and tie and then you you
project to the world how much you know
about words and terms that you just
learned 10 minutes ago why that instead
actually what I've said is and I think
we're actually going to do this I mean
over the objections of of good advice is
all of my policy briefings all of my
education I mean there's a lot that
anybody myself included for sure is
gonna have to learn to Be an Effective
president of the United States that's a
big part of the next year and a half and
I I am running to run I'm not running
first to make a point I'm running
because I believe seeing this all the
way through is my Max is the ticket to
drive maximal positive change that's
going to require a lot of learning we're
just going to tape them in forums like
this and we'll put it out to the
internet you know what if that allows
people to discover that I was not
omniscient great I am not God you know I
was on a radio interview yesterday where
somebody asked me about some term in in
U.S military history that I should know
well I didn't know it I told him that
but I said I'm also a fast study and
committed to learning which I think he
took in a good way and I meant it so I
just think that I think that
more Honesty will go a long way I think
this race will be better off if none of
us read speeches that other people wrote
for us if none of us even use a
teleprompter stick into some script but
speak from the heart that's what I'm
committed to doing I hope that keeps me
honest I I have a lot to learn and not
only am I going to learn it we'll open
source it everybody can learn along with
me that's one of the ways we're going to
do this thing starting about next month
yeah
well if you if you if you use prepared
speech you don't have faith in your
heart yeah you know you don't have faith
that you can respond to the moment in
accordance with your principles in a
dynamic manner that will involve the
audience and if you can't do that a you
shouldn't lead and B you should learn
because you can do that you can learn to
do that and and people do respond to
that much better like I've experimented
with this on YouTube because now and
then I'm trying to think through
something really difficult you know and
I'll write it out because you can make a
more coherent argument in writing and a
denser argument but then I've tried to
read it on YouTube you know and it
doesn't work
it doesn't work like it works okay you
know what I mean it's not a failure but
it's not a success the last thing I did
this was so this is a hybrid that's
worth experimenting with so I wrote this
uh statement of vision for this
Enterprise I described the arc
Enterprise and uh I wanted to share it
with people so I was going to read it
but I knew that reading wasn't very
compelling because it didn't have that
spontaneity that reveals the heart let's
say so what I did was I read like two
sentences and then commented on it and
then read another Tuesday
yeah that really worked because you see
it enables usually well it enables you
to to have your talking points at hand
you know because I'm going to try that
can you remember but it was it was very
effective for me and it kept the
spontaneity you know and so and you
gotta you can't get a plan for that you
just got but I think you have to you
have to in some ways be disciplined
about making sure that you don't just
revert to the Natural Norm of just
sticking to what you need to say and you
know what you're right I think there is
something about Legacy Media that that
sort of forces that but I don't like
just blaming Legacy Media too because I
I go on a lot of TV hits as well I don't
think you have to do it that way either
and in a certain way I think that the
last best chance for Reviving Legacy
Media is if the people who go on it
start behave stop behaving like the
cartoons that Legacy Media created for
the last 30 years this could actually be
the source of saving Legacy Media itself
just because you're given three to five
minutes doesn't mean that you actually
have to stick to those talking points
try doing it this way too that's what I
try to do when I go on television as
well but anyway this is this is good
much more effective I mean maybe it's
effective and maybe it's not right maybe
it's we'll find out this is an
experiment for me but here's what I'll
say even if even if you were even if you
were more likely to win the other way
you have your soul sucked out of you
right you're just a hollowed out husk of
yourself so if the point of winning was
to go sit in the white house then okay
that's one thing if the points actually
describe a Revival you're not going to
do that even from the White House if
you're just a holiday Alaska yourself I
don't take I don't think there is any
evidence that you're more likely to win
doing it the conventional handled poll
driven media establishment craft a
Persona way I think I looked at the
empirical evidence I can't see a shred
of evidence there's hardly any evidence
that election spending is positively
associated with with Victory good it's
not there's glad there's no evidence in
relationship to incumbents incumbent
spending is completely irrelevant to
electoral outcome there's some minor
evidence on the Challenger front that
more spending makes the difference but
you can't tell if that's because of the
spending or because the more popular
candidates are more likely to raise
money
so and you know if you look at someone
like Joe Rogan Rogan's very interesting
figure eight because he's basically
created a whole media Empire out of
nothing he still has nothing he has he
has his producer awesome affects all his
own guests well and all Rogan does is
exposes ignorance
because all he does is ask stupid
questions you know and I love it I don't
know the guy but but I'd love to meet
him some point you know he seems like
he's on to something but I think imagine
taking that spirit
to actually running a presidential and
political campaign that's what this is
going to be and so maybe it's I mean I'm
I'm certainly betting it's a formula for
success I wouldn't be doing this if I
didn't think so but I'd rather stay true
to who I am and actually putting that on
full display and being open about
learning through the process and open
sourcing that then trying to do this in
some way that projects some image of
some omniscient guy which is exactly
what the political consultant class
wants to do right they want to say
absolutely your position
they want to project the image of a
leader but who cares if that leader
doesn't actually exist and so that's how
we're going to do this and and you know
a year and a half from now we'll find
out whether it was the electorally
successful strategy or not but it is the
personally for me it's the only way that
I'm going to be able to do this and so
and so it'll be a fun it'll be a fun
test case to see this all the way
through
well I would say psychologically
there is no other Pathway to success
then
something approximating abiding in the
truth
because the truth puts reality within
you and behind you and so that doesn't
mean that that will result in proximal
success at the moment
right and that's another sacrifice that
has to be made like you know you don't
know in some Cosmic sense whether it's
time for you to be president apparently
it's time for you to run
but I would say psychologically speaking
that if you stay true to your own voice
and you're very diligent in that and you
make the sacrifices necessary to make
that possible that your candidacy will
be a success regardless of the outcome
and you might think well that's kind of
paradoxical it's like look no it's not
because for example you might you might
tilt the discussion of the election in a
Direction that's extremely good for the
country and that could be completely
independent of whether or not you win
the presidency in fact you might even do
that more effectively by running a
campaign that wouldn't be you know
crafted this time to put you in the
optimal political position and I've seen
this with other political leaders you
know like I talked to Netanyahu a while
back and he really risked his political
skin and his party's political skin to
bring in necessary economic reform in
Israel and that crashed his party and
him for like a decade
but he's back and Israel is thriving on
the economic front so you don't know not
crafting it at all I think I think not
crafting is exactly the way to go and
maybe that's my bet is that's going to
be what successfully puts me in the
White House in 2024 but I don't
fetishize that and then there's the
inverse of this too Dr Peterson which is
you could craft it to win and check the
box of winning the presidency but just
because you said the other way doesn't
necessarily mean you lose this other way
doesn't necessarily mean you even win
even if you actually numerically win the
election and sit in the White House who
cares if the person's sitting there is
just a stuffed suit that certainly was
knew how to craft how to win without
actually having something of substance
left on the inside of who occupies that
stuff suit so so it goes in both ways
actually I think that's absolutely I
think that's an almost inevitable
consequence like I saw this with faculty
members continually
so here's part of the reason the
universities are so ruined
okay so graduate student says to himself
I can't really say or write what I think
no an undergraduate says I can't really
say what I write or say or write what I
think I have to get my grade so he
compromises what he says and thinks and
then he's a graduate student he thinks
well now I'm a little higher up in the
hierarchy but I'm still not a professor
so I can't really say or write what I
think and then he's an assistant
professor and he says well I haven't got
10 years so I better keep my mouth shut
and then he's an associate with tenure
and he says well I'm not a full
Professor finally when I become a full
Professor I'll be able to say what I and
write what I think and then he's 35 or
40 and for 25 years he's practiced
deception and he doesn't have a word of
Truth left to utter and that happens to
political figures all the time and
that's how to really defeat totally true
and you know what I think that that's
the real that's what winning and losing
really ought to be defined as and then
we're making this empirical bet you
pointed out to Donald Trump in 2015. I
think empirically
you know my my bet is where yours is
where that in this moment probably is
the more electorally successful strategy
anyway but I'm less sure of that that I
am sure that this is how I'm gonna do it
because that's what's in my control and
and that's how I would love to keep I
would love to keep talking to you I mean
I've been really fortunate over the last
six years say because I've had a group
of family members and friends around me
who have their own independent
viewpoints and who want nothing from me
who constantly are interacting with me
and making sure that I'm not you know
wandering off the path in some manner
that's untoward you know and there's
been some pretty intense discussions
about that at multiple times but it is
very useful to have people around you
who you know who you talk through your
strategy the one you just laid out say
look guys I'd like you to keep an eye on
me and if you think I'm striking some
false notes or I'm starting to be you
know the great wonderful laws the
projection of the leader that you know
you can Reign me in a bit it and you
know if you do put that goal to keep
control of your tongue first and
foremost in mind then and then you have
people who can reflect that back to you
you know you can stay on the proper
track and I think the idea of of not
letting people I just can't believe
political figures have other people
write their speeches it's like I mean
they do those people craft your thoughts
I know it's either it's utterly insane
it's nothing they'll say I'll Channel
your thoughts but you know as as you
know whoever said it like arms the
channel through which thought flows
right my English my 11th grade English
teacher basically said that right if you
can't write it down yourself you
probably don't know what you wanted to
actually say but anyway here's an ask it
off for you I mean honestly honest to
God and you're you know the program Etc
you do
call me back on here and call me out or
don't call me back out here and comment
keep me honest right if you're if you're
seeing a deviation from this okay anyone
in my shoes deserves to be called out
and and roasted over it because that's
what keeps us honest
okay well let's do this this will be an
interesting thing to do in terms of what
I can bring to my audiences anyways I
mean you're going to enter this Fray
full flat out for the next year and a
half why don't we check in about every
three months or so and we can play that
by ear and you can just provide us with
an update you know that's right you can
walk everybody through the whole
experience and we can talk over these
issues continually and you call me out
whether you think I'm actually staying
true to what I what I'm setting out to
see this conversation is Ground Zero
let's do this every few months and then
and I'll give you my honest take of how
I think things are going and and if you
see me becoming what the thing that I'm
telling you I'm I'm entering this to
shake up and change call it out because
then we might as well call it quits on
the whole thing there's no point to the
whole thing even if I'm doing better in
the polling but I'm becoming some some
hollowed out husk of myself let's just
call it a day and move on because that's
not really what this whole Enterprise
was about I'd love it I'll take you up
on that okay okay good well I'll keep an
eye out and I'll try to ask you the most
difficult questions I can ask that are
real questions and that are fair you
know and so that that's always the
grounds for a good discussion we managed
that today it looks like we could do
this because we did this with Michaela
on Michaela's show a while back and it
was well and today I thought went
extremely well it zipped by and we
covered all are we already done I
thought are you kidding me I thought
we're just getting warmed up here no
we're already done an hour and 36
minutes
okay okay all right
Preamble okay yeah okay all right okay
it's a good place to wrap up good well
for everybody who's watching and
listening thank you for your time and
attention and I'm going to move with the
event over to the Daily wire plus
platform we're going to go through some
autobiographical background and I'm very
interested always in investigating to
find out how people's interests made
themselves manifest in their life in the
problems that grip them and the
opportunities that offered themselves to
them so we'll continue that conversation
for half an hour on the daily wear plus
front and so
um and so you can turn to that if you
want to follow up on the discussion VA
thank you very much today for agreeing
to talk to me today and uh
congratulations on your candidacy it's a
it's a hell of a thing to undertake and
uh you're going to be in for quite the
roller coaster ride for the next 18
months I mean I know you're familiar
with that sort of thing already and so I
look forward to talking to you again and
to those of you who are watching and
listening thank you for your time and
attention to the film crew here in
Calgary I'm still in Calgary thank you
for your time today and your uh your uh
your technological prowess and we'll
turn it over to the Daily Word plus and
ciao everybody
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com